Sergio de Mello the world's mr. Fixit
all right everyone let's get together
was powerful official in you in history
now the question is what to do with all
that power my work is in the field where
people are suffering or people need out
so boys want to see in Iraq they can
thin anybody else it doesn't have to be
you it's not easy for me to do I want
your elves in this country for you this
mission requires if ever best doesn't
look very welcome
this is Baghdad says you you still think
you can walk away after four months I do
[Music]
you hear me hey you okay
Jesus Christ just says you're Dominica
remember what happened I know what I
want for my life sir here what do you
want for yours
both together everything we're going
public can't do that Sergio you're here
to support the u.s. that's the only
reason you're here reason I'm here too
because we broke it you have no idea how
to put it back together is the UN just
to cover for the American occupation no
sir just for a second we are here
supporting the United States or the
coalition did you stay with me I have
survivors do you copy
we're running out of time you need to
leave
[Music]
you
[Music]
you